Leslie in your TED talk I believe you
said that you SAT your family down
initially and said to them I need your
blessing to do this film because I will
not be able to look at myself in the
mirror and and feel okay about not
making this movie what was that
conversation like it was difficult
because my daughter was 13 and I knew
she needed her mother and she and I have
an extraordinary bond so I was mostly
addressing her my son was 16 and a half
he could have well lived without me in
fact I think he was rather pleased um no
that's not true he's a sensitive
beautiful boy my husband is used to
having me away he's an extraordinary man
with the most educated heart who
understands the gender should know no
boundaries and no restrictions and it's
a partnership so he takes care of the
kids when I work and that's you know
been quite quite often that has happened
but my daughter needed me so it was very
important for me to communicate to her
because I knew I was going and that's an
admission because I was ostensibly
asking her permission but actually I was
telling her I was going and and I said
look you are my priority if you ask me
to stay if you tell me you need me I
will stay but and I didn't let her
answer the question so it was a form of
emotional blackmail I'm ashamed to say I
said if you don't let me go in other
words you tell me you need me I'll never
be able to look myself in the mirror
again because I feel so strongly about
this I have to act on it and she just
said of course you have to go and that
was that was it a decision well I'm sure
she heard you speaking of the story
before hand and and all the
conversations yes in fact she SAT and
watched a lot of those reports you know
indeed that the very first reporter of
the rape itself though that wasn't what
had got the fire in my belly because I
knew this was the tip of an eye
I mean we've all seen on a daily basis
these brutal hate-filled very violent
gang rapes and rapes and abuse of women
and girls happens ubiquitously across
the whole world it was the protests it
was the response to that that motivated
in fact compelled me to go because here
was a country doing what I feel every
citizen in every country should be doing
all the time until we get true gender
equality and you know the time really is
now to start demanding this with
certainty in fact last weekend or the
weekend before there's been a spate of
gang rapes of little girls in Delhi I
mean they're going on all the time but
there has been a spate of two very
brutal ones reported the weekend before
last a little four-year-old girl was
gangraped by three adult men she was
slashed from vagina to anus her face was
slashed she lay in the same hospital
that Jyoti Singh layin safdarjung
hospital and she had an operation just
as Jyoti had that lasted three hours to
fit her with a colostomy bag four years
old and she died a few days later and
that knees I heard on my Google Alert on
the way to a screening that we had in
London to mark the day of the girl it
was on that day and I was so hurt and so
in you know infuriated by this I and
Bianca Jagger who was there to support
the film that night we both were just so
outraged we called on the audience that
night to do a call to action of all
women and girls across the world on the
8th of march next year we want every
woman and every girl and every
enlightened man to come out on strike
and let the world come to a standstill
as it will as it did in Iceland some
years back when women simply stopped
they stopped taking care of the kids
they stop their subordinate roles were
there you know male bosses in much more
prominent positions with their
entitlement and they the whole country
and financial institutions came to a
standstill so we are calling on everyone
who is enlightened who cares about
gender equality to go out on strike next
March the 8th March the eighth ok
international women's day so going back
to the beginning of the film did you
already have the the family members of
these rapists lined up did you know how
to contact them because I mean you went
into some very looks like rural areas
and that's right how'd it all basically
i started off brainstorming what i
wanted the film to feel like to look
like you know really analyzing what were
my objectives in making this film i've
ended a a period of quite intensive
research in terms of just finding all
the footage i could of the reports and
this was a very very well covered well
reported incident and i started writing
a list of questions for the rapists Wow
and worked with a psychiatrist had a
forensic criminologist helped me with
some of those questions and and started
weeding around the whole you know the
whole subject very diligently and then
at a certain point i managed to get hold
of trial transcripts and of course i
also had appointed a researcher who
found some of the addresses through the
legal system because all of the court d
positions have the name and the address
so we had names and addresses but we
hadn't aligned anyone up basically it
was a question of doorstepping in pretty
much every case other than with the
prison because that was set up in
advance and i think it's very hard for
me to say because i was never faced
with this but I think if I had been told
I couldn't interview those rapists I
might just not have finished this film
or maybe not even have started it to me
that was absolutely imperative there
were three things I wanted to deliver
with this film the first was that the
protests should be amplified that they
would be the heartbeat and the pulse of
this film because they are ultimately
what made me feel very optimistic that
the time had come to deal
comprehensively with this issue that the
world has neglected and abandoned for
many years the second thing was that it
was very disturbing to me that this
young girl whose entire life was before
her was just referred to as this 23 year
old medical student in the press that
was it you know who had gone to see a
movie with a friend that's all we knew
about her and in fact until the film
came out nothing more was known about
her so it seemed to me to be crucial to
delve into and and find out and document
what we have lost in this girl's murder
and the third and absolutely vital leg
of of my objectives was to understand
why men do this and to you know if you
if you can't understand them how are you
going to change them so I needed to know
what goes on in the head of a man who
who does this to a woman who not only
gang rapes her but eviscerates her who
pulls out her intestines and you know
what his attitudes to women are where
they come from who the significant
female figures in his life had been what
he feels about them what is his notion
of manhood what is a man what's a good
girl what's a bad girl you know so there
were 150 questions I had
um Leslie what was the timeline I know
you said you'd had to use some of your
own family savings for the film I don't
know at what point you're spending money
to hire these researchers but what's the
timeline you've set your family down
you've basically said I need to do this
and I just need your blessing okay so I
made the decision to make the film on
the twenty-third of December that I know
for sure of 2012 it was a week after the
incident Oh a week after okay and it was
the point at which I'd been watching
these extraordinarily beautiful sights
of protesters pouring out onto the
street and then on the twenty-third of
December is when the protests turned
violent because the police the
government decided to crack down on them
and that was when my the fire came into
my belly pretty much and I thought I'm
going to make a film about this and
there is no question i really want to
labor this point it's so important this
was the first time in my lifetime and
I'm 57 years old it's a long life it's
the first time in my lifetime that I
have seen any country including those
who call themselves civilized and
sophisticated who have gone out with so
much passion for women's rights I mean
the world has dealt with slavery it's
dealt with totalitarianism it's dealt
with race it's dealt with so much but
it's still not dealt the question of
respect and the value of women and girls
so it's something that's very dear to my
heart and here was the India leading the
world by example on this that is why I
absolutely felt I had to amplify those
voices with this film so 20 30 December
I decide to do it I think it was early
january when i sat my family down
and then I started reading and
researching and around may I wrote the
letter to the director general of
Prisons to ask for permission it took
two weeks for her to come back and say
yes she then said she needed to get
permission from the Ministry of Home
Affairs because as a foreign I wasn't
allowed in indian jails and she applied
for that permission asked me to slightly
change my letter which i did and the
change she wanted was that I had asked
her precisely for what I intended to do
which was to interview the these rapists
she wanted me to express that slightly
more generally for the Ministry of Home
Affairs and his a convicted rapists I
did that I got permission from the
Ministry of Home Affairs I got on a
plane in July and went to start filming
now the day before I left for the first
leg of the sheet because I I did three
legs of shoot from july to December I
shot and the day before I went off i
went to take a meeting on my literally
on my way out of London I went from
coconut into London and then to india
and i took a meeting with channel and
BBC and channels were quite cynical in
their response to me they said get one
of the rapists get one of these
interviews and yes we're interested so
there are okay it's only if I get one of
the well of course everybody would be
interested if we got one of the rapist
so ah that didn't impress me much but
when I went to meet with Nick Fraser of
the BBC he was so supportive he opened
up to me as a human being and not just
as a cynical broadcaster and said this
is a very important film your passion is
palpable I like your vision for the film
and I want to support you now it takes
us a while
to work out whether we'll Commission
something I cannot tell you it'll be a
while however I do promise you that I'll
support you as Nick Fraser as an
individual I will come with you to heed
fur which is an important term
documentary market in Amsterdam and I'll
help you pitch it because he knew that
although I was a very experienced
feature film producer I had never done a
documentary I didn't know anyone in the
documentary world and I was immensely
touched and impressed by that so I
decided the BBC would definitely get it
if they said they'd commissioned it but
in the meantime it was pressing it was
urgent so I just went and carried on
shooting I didn't get any of the BBC
money until during the Edit and the
pressures financially were huge they
were really huge at one point I
literally had to go into my children's
school fees account and empty that to
carry on shooting and at this point the
BBC has funded forty percent of the
budget and we did get thank heavens some
support from worldview development
monies but very small and the rest I
have funded and I'm still carrying that
dead and i understand to this date
you've not made a penny back on the film
I've made some value have there I have
maids going back women make movies has
very sweetly given me an advance on you
know their sales of educational DVDs
because they recognized the fact that
you know and I've also been funding the
campaign's out of my own pocket so it's
it's at the point now where it's it's
very critical and and I absolutely have
to raise money for the campaigns in
order to carry on the education campaign
in in particular but you know I kind of
feel this is what I've been put on this
earth to do and so I'll do it by hook or
by crook with the filming in the prison
you're not alone doing this you have a
camera person with you yes and a sound
person and my co-producer and someone
asking the questions in Hindi so there
were a team of year I think four of us
in the room with him and of course there
was a prison guard present throughout
and you know they've been some
ridiculous accusations that i gave the
rapist a script to read to learn 16
hours i interviewed mukesh singh really
16 hours over three days and you know
all of these smear campaigns this
desperate hysterical pathetic attempt of
some sectors of the community in india
to not look in the mirror you know
they'll do anything right well I know
you said to that you thought that it
would only be the the rapists or men
that were of a certain educational group
that would have this feeling but you see
from the film that one man says that
many of the members of parliament have
unconvicted rapes on their record and
and that they've never really been
challenged and it takes so long to to
see the process through so this mindset
yeah that says that men and boys are
king they are the desired gender they
have the entitlement and the power and
girls and women are subordinate they are
destined to be domestic slaves to be
married off they don't need an education
and their unwelcome the mother of Jyothi
and they are so enlightened her parents
you know and the mother tells us at one
point that when she had this little girl
she gave out sweets because she was so
happy and the the people who came you
know the friends and family who came to
the the hospital presumably to
and saw her giving out sweet said you're
celebrating is if you had a boy why are
you giving out sweets I mean literally
that is what they do they don't
celebrate the birth of a girl so if you
grow up as a boy as a man witnessing
this what in God's name do we expect
them to go on to do and express in in
actions when they have this this
attitude bred into them their program
they're hardwired to know that a girl is
of lesser or no value to them and why
are we surprised that they then go and
commit these atrocious and hate-filled
and heinous acts we may as well give
them a rapists manual of for their 11th
birthday Leslie I know that you've
received the banning of the film in
India you've received maybe
notifications on Twitter or various
things advice for another filmmaker that
is making a an emotionally politically
charged film and still wants to carry on
a very very important message and has
the help of others around them but just
dealing with that in general what is
your advice because I'm sure there's
many other filmmakers whether it's
something no blackfish you know an Errol
Morris film this there's probably so
many others that have been in your shoes
but it's not something that's you could
just pick up a book and and find out how
to deal with it my advice is simply this
commit one hundred percent do not shy
away from telling the truth in whatever
form of expression that takes if you
care about this message just tell the
truth because apathy and silence and all
forms of negotiating the truth because
it's not quite tasteful or it's a little
bit shocking shock is a powerful tool
shock is important we don't have enough
of that we don't hear the truth enough
we've become so annoyed two concepts
that
that really deal with the most
fundamental violations of human rights
and we've become so used to them FGM we
give them little acronyms you know they
trip off the tongue so easily FGM FGM
let us not forget what that is a knife
is taken the clitoris of a woman is cut
out her labia a cut off I spoke to
Somalian girl the other day who told me
that one of the practices as amongst
husbands and wives is that if her
husband will go off on a business trip
he will sell his wife up he'll come back
and cut the stitches this is what we're
talking about and the world is what
ignoring this it's accepting it we have
to scream out we also have to not think
how will I be allowed to do this we have
to think who's going to stop me from
doing this and you know it's it's the
most important thing always is with
filmmaking i think is is committing
yourself to the truth and passion and
integrity of what you feel because you
know there were moments where i wanted
to give up there was one day where i was
giving up there was no question nothing
in the world was going to keep me there
except i happen to phone when i thought
my kids were asleep and thought i would
get my husband i was in the midst of a
major panic attack and i think it was
really it was not long after I'd
interviewed a rapist who had raped a
five-year-old girl and that just so
drenched me in the deepest sense of
profound pity for the world that you
know given the state that we are in that
that can happen and that this man could
have told me so easily that he did this
because she was a beggar girl in her
life was of no value
and I was so so depressed by all this
that I think that must have led to this
breakdown and I phoned home literally to
tell my husband to book the flight
because I didn't even have the presence
of mind to do that and my daughter had
answered the phone and she immediately
knew that I was in trouble and asked me
what was wrong and I then just burst out
crying I couldn't control myself she
then started talking me down off this
panic attack with breathing exercises
she was 13 and a half when she did this
and then her final statement to me after
telling me to write all my problems down
and then start solving a little ones
first so she gave me some very practical
advice and then she said to me and mummy
you're not coming home because I and my
generation of girls are relying on you
and that was it so I stayed but that day
I really was going to stop and and so
badly wanted to but you know the the
thing is that there are so many when
you're dealing with a difficult subject
like this there are so many reasons to
stop and not do it and there are so many
obstacles physical practical emotional
psychological that unless you have that
real compulsion you may as well not
start so once you have that fire in the
belly just go with it and go all the way
and if you go all the way that message
will get through as it's getting through
here I mean this film has sparked more
conversations about gender inequality
and this issue this pressing urgent
issue of how women and girls are treated
in every country in the world to
differing degrees and with different
characteristics it's sparked more of
those conversations in the last five
months than have been hurt in the last
decade so that can only be a good thing
and I think it's because of the shock
it's because of the one hundred percent
commitment and you know
I mean if I if I die doing this my time
on earth will have been worthwhile so
when i get these tweets you know white
you deserve to be raped or threats
to my life or pornography being sent I
just tell myself fly 30,000 feet above
this this will change when the solution
is put into effect and I have got the
solution i have to tell you because of
the insights and the perspective of
having delved so deep with such
commitment into this particular inquiry
and i just have to tell myself that you
know these are pathetic backward-looking
people who are very soon going to be
left behind when there will be new
learning and the world will change
you've been vocal about your own
situation that you experienced a rape I
believe when you were 18 or so do you
feel like you had to use that as a did
at some point as a defense because
people were coming after you because I
think there were you know the quote you
were shaming India whatever the
different accusations were or was this
already part of the story did you have
to put that up as a reason the fact that
I was raped when I was 18 strangely
enough didn't form part of the story it
wasn't part of my motivational my
reasoning for doing the film it was more
of a name of a potential impediment I
was worried about it because I'm ashamed
to tell you I didn't report that rape
and I kept it to myself for 20 years
which is the worst thing a girl or a
woman can do I told about my own rape
because I was urging girls and women on
my website or the film's website rather
to report because rape is the most
underreported crime and you know or all
of these arguments that India rapes less
than the u.s. I mean it's so it's so
utterly pathetic and and just you know
people deflecting from the issue and
trying to look in
other direction the statistics are
meaningless and and and what are we
saying my country rapes less than your
country what is that about really you
know all countries rape IE all countries
have a very serious problem with rape
and gang rape and abuse and that's what
we should be looking at but I was urging
women and girls to speak out how could I
not speak out myself so I thought I have
to you know tell everyone that I'm I too
was raped I was worried that it would be
an impediment and that is why I
practiced on for other rapists before I
interviewed the rapists in this case
because I didn't know how I was going to
react whether those demons would fly up
during the course of you know the
interviews sitting facing a rapist and
never having had the chance to address
my rapist would I physically attack one
of them I thought that was actually a
possibility I was scared of that but
that's the only way that the that
experience impinged because in a strange
way I had come to terms with what
happened to me and it's not something I
expect you know most people can do you
or do do cuz there's those traumas are
very real in my case I was so grateful
that I'd survived because I was
convinced the guy was going to kill me
after he raped me and the fact that he
didn't the fact that I got out of there
alive was such a relief to me that in a
way the rape kind of diminished into
well at least I'm alive you know it
wasn't as and and I believe I've kind of
coped with it you know so yeah so it
wasn't part of the story in a sense okay
during the the what-is-it two years that
you were actually making the film i
believe was a two and a half two and a
half okay i filled for six months then
went back in for a little more filming
uh in in january of 2014 but the edit is
what took a very long time i had 87
hours of material and that's partly
because i was so inexperienced of course
as a first-time director i was just
shooting everything and anything in
retrospect of course i would have been
more judicious because half of these 87
hours were in Hindi and I I have a
smattering of Hindi I understand more
than i can speak but i'm certainly far
from fluent so every one of those
transcripts had to be translated the
hindi ones and then i would take the
paper transcript and the rule for me in
editing this film because i had nothing
to fall back on i didn't have any
experience of you know actually
structuring a film before as a producer
I would always be very hands-on to the
great irritation of all the directors
I've ever worked with but I was hands-on
being reactive to their first cut this
time I had to create that first cut and
so I had to sit down and think okay what
is the endeavor here what is it I
actually should do in terms of
structuring this and it seemed to me
that the best thing I could do was to
try and reflect the journey I'd gone on
in terms of the insights that i glean so
i start off with a very narrow focus and
the film just or all my experience my
insight just expands and expands as i
understand that it's not just the rapist
ooh think this way it's the entire
society and so when I went through these
transcripts with my yellow highlight
marker I was picking out the things that
seemed to me to be significant in
my own personal journey through the film
because again one of the things that I
decided absolutely definitely before I
left for filming was that my voice
wouldn't be in there I wouldn't be in
there I come from feature films so my
sensibilities are all about characters
interacting the story coming you know
from the people involved in it so i took
the absolute decision that it would only
be the direct participants in the story
and in the case who would tell us the
story and I resist in documentaries when
there is a narrator leading us by the
nose telling us what sense to make of
this I think things are much more
powerful and resonant when we decide for
ourselves but the material that's laid
out in front of us is is is very you
know powerful and and forceful so that
it's you know characters are putting
their own world views and we're hit by
this and then we see at 360 degrees and
we quite naturally go with what the
truth is because the truth will always
emerge and the documentary is I think
actually quite balanced I was careful to
do that and you know even the rapists
come up with some pretty forceful
arguments and I've always allowed that
you know I didn't want to cut those out
by any means because they are who we
want to learn from there who we want to
really hear and understand so when
Mukesh says that when they now they've
changed the law and and recommend
hanging the death penalty for rape in
the rarest of rare cases well rarest of
rare just means violent extremely
violent he says rapists will now murder
the victims or the you
the girls because they don't want to be
identified so they won't take that risk
before they could rely on the sense of
shame that adheres to the rape victim
which is so unjust and shameful you know
the shame is with the perpetrator the
shame is with the society who created
that perpetrator and taught him what to
think and how to view women and so forth
for there to be any question of dishonor
or shame on the actual girl who asked us
suffer this violation of her human
rights is just completely untenable and
disgusting Mukesh tells us they used to
you know be able to rely on shame for a
girl not to tell but now that the death
penalties involved they'll they'll kill
her just to make sure that she doesn't
identify because he would also hurt her
dowry if it was if it was known that she
was raped that's right right yeah Leslie
doing those two and a half years that
you're shooting the film and going back
for reshoots what's 2am like for you
what's 3am like for you are you losing
sleep kind of tossing and turning should
I have gotten this is this really going
to work how was that for I literally had
to be on a regime and I had to train my
body to sleep three hours a night only
three hours a night if I slept more than
three hours i was in trouble because i
wouldn't have been able to complete the
task so sleep has not ever been a
problem to me because i have so little
hours I just crash the problem is if I
sleep more than three hours once I tried
that I was so exhausted and I thought
I'm giving myself another two hours
tonight and I slept for 18 hours
non-stop I just didn't wake up through
alarms and you know so no I I didn't do
you know I I don't think I've really
crashed yet and i hope i won't but i
think there's a big chance that i will
of course because it's so deep you know
what I've seen is so
deeply deeply disappointing and the one
clue I have as to whether you know I
might just crash one day is this that on
one of the filming legs I came home to
Copenhagen and my family were already at
a party there was a confirmation party
of my husband's best friend's son and I
had to go straight from the airport I'd
come home I think for a week so you know
is desperate to see them and I went
straight from the airport to the party
with my luggage and I was so overjoyed
to be there and there was such a festive
lovely atmosphere and I hugged my kids
and had my husband and then I sat at
this table and the Danes really know how
to celebrate you know and it was um I
was enjoying myself and I had this smile
on my face and I my husband beckons me
out of the room at one point um and I
went out and he held me and he just said
please tell me what I can do to help you
darling tell me and I said getting quite
emotional and I just said well why what
do you mean you know and he said you're
sitting there with this smile on your
face and the tears are streaming down
your face and I had no idea that I was
crying literally no idea so it is very
deep-seated and I i know that i will
continue for the next three years and i
will continue at this pace and i will
not stop unless I drop dead from a heart
attack but i will keep going until I get
this solution which is a human rights
global education initiative that I'm
advising the UN human rights office on
I've already got eight countries
co-opted I'm hugely optimistic and it's
the optimism that's the antidote of
course the optimism is carrying me
through I know that if we educate our
children's hearts as well as their heads
if we do this on a compulsory basis with
all the children of an adopting country
and if we do it from the first day of
entry of that child into those children
into school we
will empower girls we will change gender
stereotypes we will educate children at
the crucial stage when they are still
modifiable in terms of cognition and
when we can still modify their attitudes
and behavior that they've come to you
know even kindergarten with from home by
teaching them empathy which is not
innate it has to be taught and it has to
be practiced by teaching them respect
teaching the moral values and we are
designing and constructing a curriculum
a global curriculum exercise by exercise
very concrete very specific this is not
about oh we're going to teach them
values in some area way it is going to
be exercised based they will be taught
particular songs they will be given
particular stories they will be playing
particular imaginative play games and we
have various education philosophies
montessori and feuerstein and the United
World colleges and I be systems and
we're going to design three curriculum
one for the early years 1-4 the middle
years and one for the senior years we're
doing that over the next three years and
in 2018 the early years curriculum will
start rolling out in the world schools
of those countries that do adopt and as
I say I've got eight already and I've
only just started and at that point I'll
stop and I may make another film again
one day but I will not make another film
until I have done this because I won't
walk away from the insights and the
perspective that I have got on this film
now I've become an activist having been
you notes my first and and possibly a
swan song as a director I don't know but
I have to see this through I can't have
these searing insights and then move on
to another topic in three years time who
knows maybe then it'll all flood out of
me but I will keep it in for at least
three years till I can put this into
operation